-Yeah, all right.
Party, yeah.
I'm actually not
a very good drinker.
Like, like when my friends
are always like,
"Drink it, chug it, slam it,"
I'm always like, "I can't,
it's a daiquiri, it will hurt."
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to swallow
the umbrella.
I am not a manly man.
I know I look like
a quarterback,
but inside I'm all cheerleader.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm actually a huge
people pleaser.
Whoa, shocker, right?
Yeah, like,
even when I'm in an Uber,
I'm like,
"Hey, do you want me to drive?
[ Laughter ]
Take a load off, pal."
You know?
I figured out what Uber drivers
do not like at all --
hugs goodbye.
But it's like,
if you didn't want one,
why did you take me
to the airport?
[ Laughter ]
I'm from Wisconsin.
You don't know how I was raised.
I definitely have that vibe
about me.
Like, if I sat down next to you
on an airplane,
you would be like, "Ugh, this
guy is going to want to talk."
[ Laughter ]
And I do.
I want to talk so bad.
I choose the middle seat
on purpose
just so I have more options.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, I'm like,
"Hey, what are we talking about?
Oh, we're talking about
putting on headphones.
A lot of people have been
talking about that."
I don't know if you guys can
tell by my deep, tortured eyes,
but I've been through
some stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I went through a breakup
last year,
and I don't know if you've ever
been through one of those,
but oh, gosh, wow.
It is so fun.
Because you get to play
a game called
"Am I going to cry in public
today?"
[ Laughter ]
I was crying so hard one day
in public
that a crying baby looked at me
and stopped crying.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Dude,
how full is your diaper?"
[ Laughter ]
But crying is such a weird thing
because
when you're crying alone,
you're like,
"Nothing is worse than this."
But when you're crying
in public,
you're like, "This is worse."
[ Laughter ]
I was in an airport
going through this breakup.
I felt a cry coming on,
so I convinced myself that if
I just ate a sandwich
I would have enough energy
and calories from the sandwich
to suppress the tears.
That's not a thing.
I'm pulling the sandwich
up to my face, I'm like,
"If you just eat this,
you won't cry."
And at that moment,
a businessman in a hurry
smacks into me
and my sandwich goes "thwp!"
and one sad olive
was rolling away.
And I was like,
"Everyone's leaving me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then I just started bawling
over my sandwich.
But it didn't sound like
regular crying.
Have you guys ever been
to the point
of the pathetic hyperventilation
where your crying sounds
like pulling a straw
in and out of
a fast-food-cup lid?
[ Laughter ]
That's where I was at.
I was like, "I -- just --
want -- my -- sandwich!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I -- want -- to eat --
right -- now."
And the most amazing thing
happened --
instead of judging me,
the businessman just panicked
and he started giving me money.
He's like, "Oh, no, there's a
one, there's a 5, that's a 20.
Why isn't this working?
It works on my children."
[ Laughter ]
He gave me $38
on a $7 sandwich.
And when he walked away,
I had an epiphany.
I was like, "Oh, my gosh,
I just mugged a man...
with my feelings.
That's not a weakness.
That's a super power."
[ Laughter ]
But this story has
a happy ending
because I just started dating
a new girl
and I'm totally falling in love,
you know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, we met on an airplane.
I was like, "Yeah, middle seat's
working out.
Oh, your headphones are broken."
We got off the plane,
and she texted me.
She's way cooler than me.
She texted me, "HMU," which I
now know means, "hit me up."
Right?
I didn't know that.
I thought she was just spelling
out the sound it makes
when you send a text message.
[ Light laughter ]
I literally thought she wrote,
"hmu!"
So I replied, "eahph!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
She wrote, "No, HMU!"
I wrote, "Yes, eahph."
Finally she called me.
She goes, "What do you mean?"
I was like, "What do you mean?"
She goes, "Mine means hit me up.
What does yours mean?"
And I go, "Oh, my means E
and then eamph!"
[ Laughter ]
And I swear to you,
the first time I kissed her,
I leaned in and I go, "eamph."
[ Laughter ]
And she goes, "hmu!"
And I was like, "I'm going
to marry her, you know?"
She's way kinkier than me
because everybody is.
She goes, "What are you into?
You know, like in the bedroom?"
And I was like, "Consent."
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right, I'm Pete Lee. Thanks,
you've been a great crowd.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Pete Lee! Wow!
That's how you do it
right there.
Pete Lee.
For more, check out petelee.com.